where other states are investing
resources in how do we help these people
not come back into the prison system
California's not the United States locks
up more prisoners than any other country
in the world
and in the country holding the most
prisoners in the world California is the
state that incarcerate smore people than
any other California's prisons are so
overcrowded that the Supreme Court ruled
them in violation of the eighth
amendments cruel and unusual punishment
clause the current state of the prison
system in California is is is trouble
Adrienne Moore is vice president of
research at Reason Foundation
he says California's prisons are
overcrowded in large part because of
their inability to keep released felons
from reoffending we accept in California
this revolving door of inmates that no
other state is willing to accept and
it's way past time we started addressing
that is staggering 65% of those released
from California's prisons will one day
return more lays much of the blame with
political interest groups particularly
the state's powerful prison guard Union
the CCPOA the California prison guards
Union has long been a really powerful
political force in California they are
you know leading advocates of not
putting money into programs to reduce
recidivism but instead to put the money
into the prison guards and the prison
facilities and they are for just locking
more people up
the CCPOA and other law enforcement
groups have consistently lobbied for and
received more and more prisons and more
and more workers to staff those prisons
but building more cages hasn't
alleviated the overcrowding the more
prisons California has the more
prisoners its courts seem to fill them
up with in addition to lobbying for more
staff and funding the unions and their
affiliated interest groups have also put
political capital and lots of money into
defeating reforms to the prison system
such as prop 36 which would have
substituted substance abuse treatment
for incarceration for nonviolent
offenders or prop 66 which would have
reduced the number of crimes eligible
for a life sentence most crucially the
union was the largest contributor to
California's three strikes law it
imposes mandatory 25-year to life
sentences for third time offenders even
if the third felony is not serious or
violent we do lobby for stronger laws on
the book that we can use to to put
people away because these are people
that are preying on the citizens of
California
Ron Cottingham is the president of por
AK the Peace Officers Research
Association of California the CCPOA has
surprisingly sat out the fight against
three strikes reform this year but Porac
has contributed $100,000 to defeating a
ballot initiative called prop 36 that's
aimed at requiring the third strike to
be a serious felony before triggering
the automatic 25 year to life sentence
the people had thought that when we
voted for that law that we were going to
be putting away serious violent
criminals like murderers and rapists and
child molesters
Dorothy Erskine's nephew Brian Smith was
one of the first prisoners in California
to be sentenced under three strikes his
third strike was shoplifting linens from
a department store he served 18 of his
25 year sentence so far we believe that
three strikes is working we saw an
immediate reduction in the crime rate in
California in 1990 shortly after 1994
when it was passed and implemented the
fur
time it is true that crime has declined
since three strikes went into effect in
1994 but that decline has been seen
nationwide and in states that don't have
the same prison overcrowding problems as
California does I'm not saying that they
don't need to be incarcerated if they
have transgressed the law but I just
feel like it needs to be some type of
balance if you're looking for an
imbalance in the way people are
sentenced I mean again the person that
is is sentenced for 25 to life for
committing their third strike which
right now is any felony you're looking
at a person who is that's their
lifestyle that's what they're doing
327 California inmates received their
third strike from a petty theft more
than 3,500 are serving a 25 to life
sentence for a non-violent non serious
crime and more than 1300 of those are
incarcerated for nonviolent drug offense
our people in the drug category
something that should be looked at the
drug offense again you'd have to look at
probably have to go through the records
and look at each one or how they were
committed what type of crime it was what
type of drug it was because you know
certain drugs just by their definition
in their schedule are felonies to
possess questions of justice aside the
California state auditor's office
estimates the cost of incarcerating
these nonviolent criminals under the
three-strikes guidelines at seven point
five billion dollars but porrik and
CCPOA both say that more prisons and
more prison guards are the ultimate
solution when the Domino's start rolling
down we're naturally going to see is
there is going to be a need for more
local corrections people and for more
local peace officers there has to be a
balance to be able to to work and handle
the case those are going to come around
they are following their own
self-interest which is to have the
prison system in California continue to
be large and to grow over time and they
have been very successful at that